And everybody, I just want to make this video to go over our.
So I went over our home page and stuff of our members site.
But now I want to talk about just our courses.
So the courses. So on the courses. So the course home page is is is basically let's say I think this is the home page.
This is the kind of the landing page that you can see that go from our website that the people can go on here and click on here to order our course.
Then they'll go to if they do click to order the course.
Then they'll go to the purchase page, which is this page, which is as purchase to stop fighting cancer, start treating the cause course.
So this is how they purchase it that they pay the paypal.
So $297 is the cost of the course. Now we've added so much information that I'm tempted to charge more, but that's what it is right now.
Then they'll get a thank you. This will be the page. You're obviously looking at the back office. That's why you can see all these things. Thank you for your purchase and receive an email shortly with a link.
Then they can go to the course itself and look at all the different pages of the course. These are all the pages of the course so far, the different modules.
In the different modules, they'll see each module. So this is module one, the bandaid approach. They can see all these other modules that they can click on them. So it is not a course that they have to do one, then two, then three. It's not a course like schoolwork like that. They could just jump to module seven or module four or whatever. Right.
So actually this video is going to change that.
And then they'll be able to see, watch the little intro video and then they'll be able to watch some other videos on there.
Oh, I got into cancer and all like that. Then from there, they could jump to the next modules. But I, what I wanted to show you is these different modules and what we are offering on these modules. So this is like module two is called the Connor's method.
And I created a little video for each one of these modules, like this is a 12 minute video on this module. It could download the transcript.
But then also what we sound in our store is this hour and a half log video called the Connor's method. And it's free. It's a free download for the course. So what they would have had to pay $30 for free on the course.
And all the pages, they can link to our home website. If they want to become a patient could pretty sure that we will actually get a lot of patients on the purchasing this course. So this is not going to slow our.
Are crazy to stone. Unfortunately, I will probably speed it up.
Module two is on that's module two. That's what we just did module three. Then it's into more details, finding the cause again, I created a little video at each one of these.
They could download the transcript. This video is a little bit longer 25 minutes. They could download the book from here, free link to a whole bunch of pages on our website about causes.
These have to do it biotoxins and toxins and a whole bunch of information on our website and other video that I talk about treating the cause that I was interviewed by somebody.
And then we get into module four with addressing the transfer. So addressing the cancer short, minute video. This is where we get into protocols. So here's data protocol and a video about protocols. And then Dustin has to create a link.
To create a link to the protocol page from here. So I'll create a link to the protocol page from here. And then these are the protocols. So the main protocol page is cancer protocols.
So here's the main protocol page, personalized protocols for specific cancers, breast cancer brain cancers, upper GI cancers in all of these cancers. Okay, so these are all the different cancers that have protocols. So they could click on this breast cancer page.
And this is what they would go to. So if they clicked on the press cancer page, they go to this page. And then it lists has a video about breast cancer itself explains a little bit about the different breast cancers, just like on our website, but then it gets into more specific protocols.
Like a basic ductile carcinoma, here's supplement protocol, turkey tail complete this leaks them to the store. So they could buy these products right from our store.
A basic lobular links them to the products on the store, inflammatory breast cancer, links them to products on the store triple negative links them products of the store and other all the pages have this other cool more amenities, we do they have a digestion, they have inflammation, they have constipation, they have you know links them to things on the store.
So that's what each one of the pages looked like. So all the different protocol pages have multiple different cancers. Let's say the upper GI cancers have, you know, stomach and pancreatic and things like that lower GI would be colorectal things like that. So there's four or five or six different cancers in each page.
12 or 13 different pages. So we got 50 different cancers listed with protocols in there, which that's all pretty nice for 300 bucks that they're getting.
Then on top of that, then you that was module four, then you want to module five. That's where we talked about the right machine.
And I have a video, it's about 17 minutes long, explaining right machine, but that it says buy a true right machine with doctor cutters unique programming here, this links to the store and the page of the store that it likes to is
the right page of the store. So this page right here, this is what it likes to program right machine.
The hamburger and the census project is not available for normal retail purchases, only available to those, and we specifically offer this package following the case review or those on our stock fighting cancer education, of course, should someone purchase this, we will need to call and confirm details and acceptance for purchase.
Because we need to follow and ask if you want to have cancer, you do have. So that's how that college is going to program it. Oh, yeah, correct. Okay. So all right. That's your program it for you or that to get the details on that person.
We'll talk a little bit more to Stephanie about this, but if we have people from the store that are going to purchase a right one other step that would be nice to have is to create
a file for them in practice fusion, because if we had a file for them in practice usually we could keep track of it that way, because even though they're not patient, it still gets us they did purchase, you know, big equipment for the so we'll talk about that.
So that's the module five has a whole bunch of other videos on the right and understanding frequencies, and that video that I shared on the signal platform on can I buy a program right is on here, but then another link at the bottom to buy the program rice.
That module six is is clean up the environment. Again, I have a video on that. And this is where we push people to the genetic review. So consider a genetic review.
What we need from you, what you received from us, this explains a genetic review that they'll have a link to the group zoom call.
And they can order the genetic review right here from there, they would be pushed to this page on the website, which is this one right here, it's $1,000 genetic review.
So this explains it. Again, the solely available, those are patient members have already had a case review or members of the stop fighting for course.
And then.
And then module seven is where we get into the spiritual aspects of it and share download of the book and a video right there.
We got a lot of that book. So you made part of this is seven modules and then you got all the cancer protocols.
And which there is a lot of them and the ability to purchase the genetic.
Only plan and the ability to purchase the right only plan right directly from there.
So I just think it's going to be great. And here's the stuff I'm using.
And that has the introduction and that has the different modules on it, how to start each monitor.
Hopefully that was good introduction to this course.
And you can push people to the course, just even from our website now. So on our website on any one of the pages, you'll see this up here courses books blog video store begin here.
So all you have to do is tell people, oh, well, just go to the go to our website and click courses. And then this is the course page that I showed you. So right from here they can buy that next thing that we're going to do that will do get that July hopefully is this.
And we're going to have a specific course on genetics and cancer. And then we're going to have a course online. And we're going to have a course on about two different step.
Of course, how to make courses that will be the next question.
So this will be a nice little addition that will be helpful to carry on to our country.
Hopefully it's a pressure off. So hopefully that helps. And bye.